today
okay let's get uh started
welcome to the Simons Institute
um my name is venkat guruswami and I'm a
senior scientist here at the Simon's
Institute for the theory of computing uh
for those who might be you know watching
who may not be familiar yet the Simon's
Institute is the leading international
venue for collaborative research on
theoretical computer science and it
brings together world's leading
researchers in theory of Cs and related
fields as well as the next generation of
outstanding young scholars every
semester so it was uh started with a
generous Grant from the Simons
foundation in 2012 and is just entering
the second decade of its programs so
typically the assignments Institute runs
two programs each semester Each of which
brings around 70 long-term visitors
junior or senior to Berkeley and the
programming the scheduled programming of
each of these thematic semesters
includes a boot camp as well as three
workshops spread through the semester
and for which additional visitors come
to work and it's my pleasure to welcome
you to the workshop on epidemics and
information diffusion which is the
second of three workshops in this
semester's program on graph limits and
processes on networks from epidemics to
misinformation
so I would like to sincerely thank the
organizers of this week's workshop for
their hard work in putting together a
great program so they are Abba ghumal
Malvina lushak Muhammad akbarpur Amin
saberi and Alessandro vespignan
and thanks to all of them
foreign
just I'd like to cover a few logistics
for the coming week before handing it
over to um above for the introduction to
the workshop so food is provided before
the first talk and in the breaks and
it's just outside the auditorium here
for lunch you're on your own but there
are many great options nearby in walking
distance and we ask that you please
leave any food and drinks outside the
auditorium and just consume them in the
breaks but I'll not bring them inside
and if you have any AV issues uh far is
always around to help speakers get set
up and uh also a reminder that the all
all events in uh Simon's Institute are
live stream so this Photoshop is also
live streamed uh so anyone can watch
right uh and finally a special thanks to
our events team who are key to putting
all these programs together a week after
week uh so that is kelani Penland Ashley
Hassan and Elizabeth un for managing all
the logistics both here as well as
things like accommodation so big thanks
to them
to introduce
thank you very much and
yes uh welcome all to this second of the
series of events uh lineup under the
program on uh graph limits and processes
on networks from epidemics to
misinformation so we're welcome you all
my name is ABBA gamelk I was at Arizona
State University recently moved to the
University of Maryland so the workshop
is uh on epidemics or information
diffusion so in a second we had the
bootcamp last year in August I think
August 29th to September 2nd so this
particular Workshop brings together a
multi-disciplinary team of researchers
from computer science from mathematics
from epidemiology from economics
public health and to to come together to
address important problems associated
with the spread of diseases on social
networks and also the spread of
so that's the purpose uh
to connect a rigorous analysis of
processes which model the spread of
infectious diseases or pathogens in a
social network but with the main goal of
developing predictive models
as well as effective Public Health
policies and algorithmic solutions for
the control and mitigations of those
diseases so that's the main the main
theme of the conference this also
entails epidemic models used to to study
and model the spread of new ideas new
technologies
information and misinformation
I've mentioned organizers
from University of Melbourne Muhammad
Akbar poor from Stanford the last two I
they deserve special mention so I mean
it's a very right here and also
Christian moves those others too this
will never ever happen I mean even they
are the main pillars for all of these
events I mean it's amazing how much they
work so much how they put into all this
and just how very efficient they are so
I'm very thankful to all the
co-organizers for this but specifically
I mean and Christian
we thank you also to the Simons
Institute for the support and also for
administrative support Elizabeth Ewan
has been fantastic the associate events
coordinator uh also Christian Wang
Sunday Ronnie the deputy director and so
on so
this uh we have a series of exciting
lectures uh lined up and we'll start the
very first one
today and I think uh for those of us in
mathematical
epidemiology Tom Britain requires
absolutely no introduction whatsoever
this is
and I didn't prepare any
and it slides to only write-up to talk
about his uh background because it's a
name that uh very well known
uh but the talk today is of epidemic
models with manual and digital
contractors but I should also mention
one of the major work done on the model
of covid-19 yeah the last few years I
think was his paper in science that
talked about
uh how complicated the notion of party
immunity is when you incorporate
heterogeneities
so
great to read and anyway so it's my
great honor to welcome Tom Britain from
stockholf University in Sweden to give
the very first talk for for this session
thank you for the nice introduction
thanks for uh
invited me to this nice Workshop
and uh being staying here for several
weeks I'm enjoying it very much both
scientifically and also
the surroundings are very nice to see as
well
so uh I don't think I will use the full
hour but we will see so please interrupt
me if there are questions because I
don't have all that much to say I would
say
anyway I will talk about contact tracing
it's both manual and digital so digital
is the contact tracing through these
apps but in a modeling perspective so
it's not that I'm analyzing data or
anything
so this is Joint work with a PhD student
of mine
yeah
so um
well in her PhD thesis and our ultimate
goal is quite ambitious
we would like to consider both manual
and digital contact tracing
we don't want them to be perfect in the
sense that not all manual contact
tracing are able to reach the contacts
and also not everyone is using the app
also uh we would like to have sort of
two sorts of contacts random contacts in
the community at large but also context
takes in place on some social uh
structure it could be a network or
households or whatever so we would like
to have sort of a one rate at which you
mix with people in the population at
large and another rate at which you meet
with your day-to-day friends or
something like that
so that is what we were aiming for
and maybe I should have had this uh
taking place so think of a situation
where you meet people around them maybe
people on the bus or in the shop or
something
and you're at risk of infecting others
or getting infected but also you meet
your
your friends that you meet regularly if
you were diagnosed and being asked to
who have you been in contact with
probably you would know the ones your
friends that you've had contact made but
you wouldn't be able to say yeah I sat
next to
when you don't know who you sat next to
on the bus or who you met in the suit so
when you manually contact Trace maybe
that only takes place on the socially
structures situation but not on among
the random context whereas the digital
contact tracing works on in both
situations
um also we would like to have a delay
between so so suppose I'm diagnosed test
positive today
and probably it's not that immediately I
am a question for who have might be in
close contact with and they would be
reached immediately so probably there's
a few days of delay we would like to
introduce that into the model as well
and also
if I name my friends
or in the digital app they are warned
um
if those people are test positive
usually they go test themselves
there's an additional delay and if they
test positive also they would be contact
raised for their contacts so the contact
Trace happens iteratively
all this is what we would like to do
however we haven't succeeded
so uh yeah at least so
uh
we don't consider uh so far we haven't
considered infections on a network or
anything so we just look at the
homogeneous contacts
unfortunately but this is something
we're working on right now I'll say a
few words at the end but we have no
delay and I think that's the most
all models are wrong some are still
useful as books they once said but I
think this is the biggest disadvantage
with our model so if I'm test positive
in our model
the contacts that have I will name them
immediately and they will be reached
immediately and tested immediately so
that's not very realistic
we do consider iterative contact tracing
probably
if someone if I'm
I mentioned that I've been in close
contact with these five people if two of
them are tested and they are currently
infectious they would be contact raised
maybe one was
recovered a few maybe last week maybe
that one would also be contact Trace but
someone that tested that was infected
five weeks ago probably would not be
contact Trace but we assume that we
contact Trace everyone who has been
infected so maybe you can think that
it's both a testing of the
carrying viruses but also an antibody
test and also the one having antibodies
would be contact Trace not fully
realistic but that's what we have
I will come back to the model later
and well we don't have any social
structures of that reason uh
we were not the this point is not
relevant to say and
we focus
exclusively on the initial phase of the
epidemic
so that's the situation we have managed
to treat so far and we are working on
you can see a delay
in being diagnosed and a successful
contact tracing
so a few words about the epidemic model
first about the general epidemic model
I'm assuming most of you guys know
epidemic models but still let me say
which one I'm considering so it's a
stochastic
or epidemic I'm looking at the finite
and fixed population of size n and I'm
looking at the situation where M turns
to Infinity
uh I assuming homogeneous mixing and
also I assume that the model is
markovian
so the model says that we infect each
any infectious person has infectious
contacts at rate beta
during your infectious period so it's
not the time varying infectivity or
anything it's a constant infectivity
rate beta
and each time you have such a contact so
this follows a poisson process with
constant intensity and each time you
have such a contact it is with the
uniformly selected individual from the
population so there's no population
structure
and if you have contact with someone
that is susceptible that person gets
infected if you have contact with
someone that has already been infected
and even perhaps recovered the contact
has no effect
and so that is a rate beta and the other
parameter is that infectious individuals
recover at rate gamma so this is the or
covian assumption I think we will hear
talks today where this is relaxed so you
have a maybe a general distribution of
the Infectious period but I'm assuming
that it's exponential
foreign all these things are defined to
be mutually independent
we start with everyone
being susceptible except one index case
and the epidemic this epidemic goes on
until the first time when there's no
infectious individual and then the
epidemic stops
for this model is well known that the
reproduction number is the infection
rate multiplied by the duration the
average duration of the Infectious
period which is one over gamma
and like more or less always
a positive
or a major outbreak is possible if and
only if there's basic reproduction
number exceeds one
so this is the epidemic model without
contact tracing that I will be
considering so are there any questions
about that
okay it is known that so that when you
Analyze This models stochastically
when n is large in the beginning since
more or less everyone is susceptible
it's very unlikely that you happen to
have a contact with someone that has
already been infected
so it means that beta is actually the
rate at which you infect new individuals
since nearly all of your contacts are
with susceptible people so any
infectious person in the beginning
infects at rate beta and recovers a
trade gamma so if you replace the word
infect and recover by giving birth and
dying you are in the regime of a
branching markovian branching process
which is also birth and death process
this is known to happen with large
probability as n tends to Infinity so
the epidemic behaves like a branching
process or a birth and death process a
linear birth and death process
data and that's right yeah
and quite a lot is known about branching
processes so you can compute what's the
probability that we have a small
outbreak in the epidemic that would
correspond to what's the probability
that my branching process goes extinct
what if you pair what's the probability
that you have a major outbreak that's
the same thing as the branching process
explodes Beyond oh grows beyond all
limits
and you can also compute what's the
probability that exactly five people get
infected that would be uh what's the
probability that my branching process
has total progeny five so you can do
those things and by beginning I'm a bit
vague but one possibility is to Define
define the beginning uh as top 100
square root of when people have been
infected
so not the big fraction but the large
numbers
foreign
all right
so now let's go to the first case with
manual contact tracing
first of all in order for a con for
contact tracing to happen also in
reality you must test positive
so not everyone tests positive some
people recover without reaching the
authorities the public health agencies
and those people are not contact risk
for that reason
um we look at the situation where an
individual can stop spreading either
because they recover naturally and we
say that happens at Red Gamma or if they
diagnosed at rate Delta I don't know if
these words are correct but you can
think that at rate gamma you don't reach
you sort of stop spreading and don't
reach the the authorities and the trade
beta
uh you stop spreading because you have
been diagnosed positive and you have
been isolated
but sorry Delta did I say something else
okay yeah Delta so Delta is rated we
should diagnose Delta for diagnosed and
Gamma natural recovery and those people
are not uh conferences
of course the more you test the bigger
Delta gets but also some people go to
the testing themselves without the yeah
so
so this is not really contact tracing
adding this diagnosis is not contact
tracing and we if you also have this
risk of being diagnosed or chance of
being diagnosed
right the reproduction number is then
beta times
either of these things event happens so
it's beta over gamma plus Delta so I
will actually call this my basic
reproduction number even that of course
the more you test so maybe it shouldn't
be equal the basically production number
but this is anyway without contact
tracing so I will compare what happens
if we introduce contact tracing in
relation to this situation where we do
diagnose people but we don't contact
rates do the digest people are they take
it to another compartment yes you can
say to them that that's a good person so
uh
the boats stop spreading whether you're
so
so you need to go here
or
naturally recovered and here you're
diagnosed
infectious and there is a circle and if
you end up here
but I haven't stopped but here we will
contact Trace those people that comes on
the next slide but here you will not be
contactless
so it's a yeah the two options I'm
called the more testing you do the the
bigger fraction will end up here so they
are both losses out of the eye glasses
yes
they hear well here you have recovery so
you're immune If you're diagnosed and we
we treat them as you then you're
isolated and you don't so you stop
spreading that's a good very good
oh
okay
so now how about the manual contract
Trace sorry a manual contact tracing an
individual who is diagnosed so an
individual
that comes here
uh is instantaneously I I said this
problem with a model that there is no
delay in the model instantaneously the
person is questioned for its contacts
and
maybe you have had five contacts and
then the model says that each of these
contacts we manage to successfully reach
them test them and isolate them with
probability P so p is
sort of a
that is a model yeah so the model
parameters transmission rate recovery
rate diagnosis rate and this P it's the
probability or the fraction of the
contacts that are successfully contact
traced yes so right now
um you're talking about at the beginning
so my question's not entirely relevant
but
um say that I have had a contact with
you but I didn't I didn't actually
transmit to you but you got named but
somebody else has affected you
that's not the likely thing early in the
epidemic but do you have thoughts on
whether you're thinking about
you as then being somebody that might
get tested or is it just yeah so later
on in the epidemic that's something you
have to deal with and um
but there is a mathematically tractable
uh Choice okay which is not the same as
the realistic choice because you
what is it you
you could be named by someone who you
did not infect or something and that
would of course happen I maybe I was
infected already but later I had a close
contact with someone so the person
didn't really infect me but I had a
close contact with them so that's why it
makes it much harder to analyze later on
in the epidemic and that's why I said
that is the reason why we haven't
analyzed the main part of the epidemic
is there a possibility of me naming the
person who infected me
yes yes so all uh yeah
actually all contacts but of course a
contact with someone
where there was no transmission going on
in the beginning that those people will
also be tested but it will have no
effect yes so you contact Trace both
upwards and downwards uh yeah forward
and backwards
so once you're diagnosed you're
immediately concentrate yes you're
isolated
[Music]
yes I think so
but that also depends on the specificity
and sensitivity of the tests that you uh
okay we have not considered this this P
yeah
maybe this specificity on sensitivity is
captured in P but the question was if p
is equal to one so you contact Trace all
contacts
then uh then it's a correct comment that
the
then you would say yes for most of me
that's probably that's okay but I think
for cover which has
I think for all the models p is not the
pay is never even close to one yeah
because
we have the prison Demarcus so we take
their blood something yeah
and of course you
you wouldn't name it so all I'm
considering is homogeneous context so
yeah you would be able to name all the
people that you have been in close
contact with so it's a correct comment
but I think
from a practice good point of view I
don't know if it makes a big difference
because my guess is that please
but not even close to one yes uh yeah
you have not qualified the number of
contacts
so this is included in Pizza mode
the number of contacts yes that that you
are declaring
well if you have the
you have the context at Red Beta so uh
when you're diagnosed you might have had
the Seven contacts and then you reach
and then you were infected by one so
that's an additional eight context and
then each of them you reach with
probability so p is a probability that
each contact is indeed is
I named them and they managed to find
the person and they test the person yeah
so it includes everything
yes
I'm not sure about this comment from
keywords one because to still have the
camera right
so what just happens is there's some
probability data over data plus comma
sort of hits
so if I so this will just reduce your
probability of outbreak but it will not
completely stress because it could just
just if I'm not times gamma divided by
gamma plus beta it's still smaller than
one
test passive including the recovered
yeah we also if you find someone that
has recovered
I I said this in the beginning I said
it's not fully realistic but there are
antibody tests so it's not the
yeah we would like my guess is that you
would contact Trace those that are
currently infectious and probably those
that recovered at one or two weeks ago
but probably you will not contact with
someone that was infected
two months ago
so you couldn't so if you instead just
go to contact results
which they are diagnosed
that seems because I could see the
contentation those that are diagnosed is
completely useless because they have
already been diagnosis
so if so if I it would seem more
realistic to me to just say okay I have
a cover
okay you never see because
in particular these days your home tests
and stuff but even before it's also if
people have been covered they wouldn't
go to the top Target they're just except
spontaneous to be covered unlikely will
ever be able to contact us so if you
instead have to model then you say okay
if you go to the recovered state to your
data due to the data process a contact
choice if you go due to the camera
process
suppose you infected me
today
in three days from in two days from now
you recover
and in five days from now I test
positive
to me it's not completely unrealistic
that I would name yes I had close
contact with Chris uh five days ago so
let's go and test him and then if you
test yes you have recovered but you were
infectious three days ago so why not to
iterate the contact rates okay
maybe that would not be the case if
found some that was infectious two
months ago maybe you would not continue
iterate that I agree but it's not
completely unrealistic
okay
so I will sort of come back how we
analyze this model
but now so this was manual contact
tracing now I will say how we model
digital contact tracing
yeah
and as you know I don't know how it was
in the use in the US but some countries
introduced an app
which sort of recorded who you were I
don't know exactly how the definition
was if you were close enough to each
other for five minutes or something like
that but I'm assuming that it works
perfect so however
yeah so as before people are either
diagnosed or recovered naturally so I
just like before I will treat this as my
basic reproduction number this is when
there is no contact tracing but there is
diagnosis but now
a fraction pie of the community uses
these apps
and follow its instructions the ones
that use the app but don't follow the
instruction I I count them as not using
them so Pi is the people that use the
app and follow the instructions
and also I assume that there is no
authoritivity or disassociativity in the
sense that you don't make if I'm an app
user I don't mix more with other app
creators or less with other app users
probably that could be included in the
model but I'm assuming that there's
no uh so this associativity or certainty
in respect to abusing
and
the model then says that if I'm an app
user and I'm diagnosed then immediately
all my contacts
are instantaneously informed and that is
actually true for the app so there is
less delay in the app user so here I
don't see this as a big problem but in
the manual it's a bigger problem
and of course they would not test
immediately they are asked to isolate
and to test themselves of course there
is a delay before they test but I'm
neglecting this delay
and if they are dying so if they are
infectious they would isolate and also
those uh their contacts would be contact
Trace their app using friends would be
contacted
or I mean
their friends
each friend has has the actual problem
with high and not there yet but if you
have the app this would probability one
that you want
so here are the model parameters are as
before but rather than P which was a
fraction of successful contact here Pi
is the fraction of app users so that's a
sort of a qualification of how effective
this
so this this assumes that anyone who
needed to be tested will get tested
tests and kits are available so sorry
diagnosis no but contact raising us it's
not that everyone is tested some people
recover naturally and they will not be
tested
it's still the situation that
if you're infectious
you would like to recover naturally or
you might be diagnosed and of course how
what fractions that go here depends on
how much testing there is actually
usually so that will affect this Delta
and Gamma so in the rate of going up
here is gamma that's probably not
nothing you can do much about but this
Delta is something you can do something
about so the more you test exactly the
more likely is it that we die a bigger
fraction of the infected people will be
diagnosed and of course that will help
in the contact tracing if if no people
are diagnosed then contact tracing will
not be very useful
okay
it's been dead yes
but let me note one thing that Pi also
as a fraction of
my contacts that I knew their names and
maybe had their telephone numbers and
that responded but Pi is now the
fraction
that use the app and for a contact
tracing to happen between two
individuals both these individuals need
to use the app so
that's why maybe pi squared is a more
natural quantity to compare with than Pi
but just
and of course you can combine the two
and just like before we treat this or
not as both natural recovering testing
and now
an individual who's diagnosed is
immediately contact traced with manual
contacts
if the person was diagnosed is an app
user all the app using friends are also
contact traced so you can be if you're
an app user there is both manual contact
tracing to the non-app users and among
the app users you have a hundred percent
contact tricks
so there you have both of these
parameters
assume that the app is perfect the app
is perfect yes so that you could
yeah I think that could be I haven't
thought but I think that could be sort
of interpreted in the pie but maybe it
should be interpreted in the pi squared
I'm not 100 sure but uh yeah I'm
thinking of pi as the people using the
app and following all the instructions
and of course in reality you would
probably this mobile thing would miss
the very short the context and the the
you could have infection there as well
so probably we should have
sort of something you relating to that
as well
I'm sorry to bother you yeah we're also
looking at the scenario where
contact tracing can realistically
for example
we're having like one million new cases
a day confirmed cases how do you have
the
required number planning of contact
traces that can yes so that's a good
comment yeah I can save myself by saying
I'm looking at the initial phase of the
epidemic when they're not one million
you're right that this assumes that you
have an infinite amount of contact
tracing people
okay
so how do we analyze this model well the
problem is contact racing model
is that you break this Independence
because in the traditional epidemic
models if I get infected then
I behave more or less independently of
the person who infected me
but when there is contact tracing that
thing is is broken this Independence
so
um you can no longer approximate it by a
branching process well at least we
haven't been able to do that
however
we can look at sort of
to be traced components
and treat these components as
individuals
in a branching process so for instance
if
well one thing think about this manual
contact tracing I said that there's a
probability P that you will contact
Trace someone
from a probabilistic point of view you
can toss this coin P at the time of
infection and it would mean that
one if the person gets diagnosed
contact tracing will happen
so you can do that already from the
start so then there are two types of
infections an infection where there will
be a manual contact tracing later on or
there can be a manual contact tracing on
that's one type of infection another
type of infection is an infection where
there will not be a contact raising
event
and for those the later type of
infections
those individuals will behave
independent from each other
so
so then you can sort of look at okay
I get infected
maybe I'm affected by someone who will
there will be no contact tracing link
then maybe I infect three people that I
will possibly contact Trace later they
belong to the same component but then I
in fact some other people that I will
not contact trace or they will not
contact Trace me they belong to new
components So within such a component
there is only contact tracing links and
outside to new components it's
non-contact racing links and those
things will behave independently so
here's a figure trying to illustrate
this
the gray means white is infectious
gray is naturally recovered susceptibles
are not in the figure
and black you see if you're diagnosed so
this person was infected
in fact that one person here and the
coin tossing whether to contact Tracer
knows what's decided that there is no
contact tracing going with there will be
no contact tracing along this link
so that's why it produces a new
component and here there's an affection
and here there will be contact raising
later on
same here and then this person recovers
naturally
and this person affects someone recovers
naturally it fixes sorry affects this
one and then this person recovers
naturally this one affects someone
whether it's a non-contact racing link
so that starts a new component and
whenever
someone and then by chance this guy
infected two people and then was
diagnosed and when this is diagnosed the
whole component
is killed because this was diagnosed and
there was a contact tracing link here in
a contact tracing link here so all these
three individuals
but all these two are also diagnosed and
isolated
so these components
once a new component is born it behaves
completely independent of its ancestor
and the other way around
so the branching process is not for the
in the original individuals but for
these components
so how does this component behave
well it starts by one person
being infectious
and it's in fact there there was a no
contact tracing link to its infector
and then it grows so now it's we we keep
track only of the number of infectious
people
so it can grow by one
they'll grow by one if this person
recovers it decreases by one
and if this person and let's say here so
here it grows
start with one then two
then three and then this person was
diagnosed so then the whole thing was
killed so
it goes up by one it can go down by one
if one of the two individuals recovers
or it can be killed the whole thing
and that is probably on my next slide so
if we keep track of
so s now is the time since such a
component was was born
and we count the number of infectious
individuals in such a component this can
increase by one
and what is the rate that it increases
by one well each of those infectious
individuals have contacts at the rate
beta but it's only with probability P
that's such a that it's a it's a contact
tracing link between them and it's for
each infectious individual
it decreases by one if one of the compo
it decreases by one
if one of these two people recovers
naturally
this happens at rate gamma times the
current number of infectious individuals
and it drops to zero if any one of the
individuals is diagnosed
so we have it's like a birth and death
process where this killing of the whole
component as well
however during as it evolves it will
also give birth to new components and
what is the rate for that it is rate
beat that times the probability that
there is a non-contact tracing link and
each individual does this so you see
it's all linear in the current number of
infectious individuals
so
this thing goes up by one down by one or
is killed
but between each jump it gives birth to
new components so how many and all this
happens at linear rates so how many
births will there bursts of new
components will there be before a jump
well if we have these rates it's just
this is the the probability to have a
birth
rather than a jump is this thing divided
by the sum of all rates so we will have
a geometric number of births between
each jump of the process
and the reproduction number in terms of
these components
is the expected number of new components
produced by one component before it dies
it is
the number of uh
births of new components between each
jump and if we let N denote the number
of jumps up until this process goes down
to zero we get this expression
but I mean the two expressions in terms
of parameters are a bit more complicated
but anyway this is the general reasoning
of it
right
components
cannot grow to Infinity
into this right yeah because it is
killed the positive
so if there is diagnosis if there is no
diagnosis if all people recover
naturally then there will be no contact
tracing so then
yes so is it um correct to think of this
as like it's a branch it's like a
ranching process how's Earth death
processes almost yes it's a branching
process of
consider this thing as your component
and this thing
it's like a birth death process with the
additional thing of a killing event yes
so like each individual is kind of
process it doesn't have to go to zero
because at the 100 process were can be
killed from a branching process
with this thing will eventually be
killed because wherever you are now
there is supposed to be ready to go on
down yes yes
so it's a branching process not the
original individuals but of these type
of components so of course over time
they evolve but we look at from the
burst until this thing is killed right
how many new components did that give
birth before it is a linear breakdown
process with an external yes that is a
component yeah
now if you generate a lot of components
that says
because then each of them is sort of
small but the largest one will be a
forward login
probably yeah
my talk will be shorter but a lot of
questions all my time that but that's
good though
so I like
um so the reproduction number we
I skipped some details here but I said
that the number of jumps between sorry
the number of external infections so the
number of new component components born
between a jump in this burst and death
process is geometrically distributed and
dependent independent between each jump
so the total number of external
infections is the sum of these geometric
distributions but it's it's around the
number of components in randoms because
his birth and death process how many
jumps does it do until it goes down to
zero so that's a random quantity in
which you can sort of Express
so you can get an expression for this
reproduction component reproduction
number
then okay what does this mean really so
if this is four what does that mean
it means that a component gives birth to
on average four new components before it
is killed but okay well
you wouldn't say that to a sort of
Public Health agent well the component
gives birth to four new components they
want to know what's the individual
reproduction number
and then you can actually
Express that as well so this component I
tried to describe it grows like a birth
and death process with killing how many
individuals on average will be born in
this component you can compute that mean
it's called that mean mu for the so this
is the average number of individuals
born before such a component dies
so maybe that is let's say it's 10 or
let's say it's 5
one person of those five were infected
from outside but the other four were
infected from inside so the number of
internal infections
is Mu comp minus one
and how many external infections well
that that is actually this reproduction
number
so if this was 7 it means that seven new
components were infected from outside
but these are actually one k person in
each time so the total number of
infections produced by such a component
is is external reproduction number plus
the internal number of infections
and
well and then if we divide by the mean
size we get an individual reproduction
number
and
this is not we had a oh it should say
reproduction number this is not the true
basic reproduction number whatever that
means we had this sort of discussion
about that last week but it is a
reproduction number an individual
reproduction number in the sense that
whenever this is bigger than one this is
bigger than one
so this is a more natural reproduction
number I would say
so this is how we did in the manual
contact tracing
with the digital contact raising
it's not the same because now we
actually have two types of individuals
we have the app users and the non-app
users
the app users they infect non-app users
that would be a new component because if
an app user in fact a non-app user there
will be no contact tracing but if an app
user infects another app user that will
belong to the same component
and if you are a non-app user you can
infect another known app user so that's
just another individual but you can also
if you are an app user you can infect
sorry if you're a non-app user you can
infect an app user and that will start a
new component
so here it's a two type branching
process
one of the type is such an app using
component and that will grow and and die
more or less like this component that I
talked about earlier not exactly the
same but in the same Spirit but the
other individuals are the non-abuses so
these are individuals
but these are components
it is an illustration a circle is an app
user so an app user
infects another abuse or another app
user that is in the same component but
here an app user infects a non-app user
that's just a comp an individual of
itself in this app user effects sorry
this non-app user infects another
non-app user and then is diagnosed if
this person is diagnosed nothing happens
so it's maybe not pedagogical that's a
black book next to it but if this is
diagnosed it has no effect except that
that person stops spreading this non-app
user also infected an app user
which starts a new component and by
chance this person was diagnosed and
when this person is diagnosed the whole
component is killed
I I will go in less detail here because
I want to move on a little bit so here
we have a two type branching process and
we try to compute the
the Next Generation Matrix
and the hard one is this one
this is an app using component how many
non-app user does it infect during all
of its life that you do in a similar
fashion as before
and the reproduction number is then the
largest eigenvalue to this Matrix
and then for the to be traced components
I will just go to the figure here I
think
this is an app user
if an app user infects
so here a dashed line means that there
is no digital contact tracing or manual
contact tracing here an app user intakes
a known app user so there could be a
solid line
for instance here is such a solid line
no sorry here is such a solid line so
this means that the app user infected a
non-app user and there will be a manual
contact tracing but here there will not
be a manual contact tracing so for that
reason it creates a new component
is it black box or not sorry
your first line there says that the
circles are the accusers yeah oh that's
that's probably that's incorrect then
I would say
this is
I think it doesn't matter if the only
Dash lines you have are between circles
and squares so
yes that's that's the only between
between uh
no not you sorry between up between
circles there's there will always be a
solely disorganizer
it could be digital here they could be
sorry a dash uh maybe the figure isn't
very clearly but anyway so we have one
one component but there is one
difference here this one is started by a
non-app user and this one is started by
an app user and they will actually have
different properties so the type here we
still have a two type branching process
and the type is defined by who is the
index case is it an app user or is it a
non-abuse if they will have slightly
different distributions
and you compute just like before uh the
Next Generation generation well just
like before it's a bit complicated but
I'm not going to how that's done and the
reproduction number is the largest
argument
foreign
okay so that is how we analyze things
and now let me show some numerical
illustrations to see if we learned
anything from it I think we learned a
little bit but let's see
let me point out that in all the models
contact tracing is in initiated when
someone is diagnosed
I mean if this one is zero
contact tracing doesn't help so
and the bigger this is of course the the
easier the the better with the contact
so I will not
I will what is the probability of going
here as opposed to here that is Delta
over gamma plus Delta so I will see how
effective are these methods as a
function of
the probability of going here and as a
function of this pi and as a function of
this P that's what I will show
so the next slide I will have a heat map
of the component reproduction number for
manual
as a function of
the diagnosis probability
and this P which is the fraction of
context that our
successfully contact traced
so yellow means a large reproduction
number and blue means a small
reproduction number and here I think the
value one goes
it's not that it looks like a nice uh
sunrise or Sunset it's very surprising
that
if you fix this probability here is very
surprising situation so you fix this
probability so you have a fixed
probability of being a
diagnosed rather than naturally recover
and then we improve contact tracing
the reproduction number grows how could
that be
the detective look
identify more cases yes but you would
expect the reproduction number to
decline them of course
the more people you detect and contact
Trace you would expect a decline
uh
sorry to isolate people
if p is
so if you reach 20 percent of your
contacts
and contact Trace them or if you reach
50 of your quantize and contact trades
and you will take the the contact
tracing is better if you reach 50 so you
would expect a reproduction number to
decline but here it goes the other way
around and why is that
no it is that we are considering the
component reproduction number and that's
a different thing because
this means that component
the number of new components produced by
one component actually does
increase
but on the other hand the size of a
component decreases
so
this reproduction number is not relevant
for public we should be we should look
at the individual reproduction number as
well
and that looks the way as one would
expect so that was because we started
doing this and I said this can't be too
so we looked in the code did we do
everything there's a branching
Proclamation correct blah blah blah but
then finally we realized that okay but
it's that we should instead look at the
individual reproduction number and then
we see this it should decay in this
direction because the more people we
diagnose should reduce the reproduction
number and it should decay in this
direction because the bigger fraction
that we
managed to reach in the contact tracing
that should reduce the reproduction
number and it did when we looked at the
individual reproduction
yes so that's an important thing both
are thresholds in the sense that if
they're lower than one we will not sell
picks and if they're bigger than one so
that's a good comments sorry sorry
so that must mean that when you look
they are near to this restaurant it must
be because it can't be that one officer
is for the low perfectly as a
result the I didn't accept foreign
[Music]
hi
um what is this
area invisible access so this is
the problem is that we cannot compare
the reproduction number because for the
manual we had two reproduction and the
component and the individual but if you
remember for the digital we had a two
type
branching process so the reproduction
number there was the largest eigenvalue
so if that is four should we compare
that with this one being four or that
one being they're hard to compare so
instead we looked at like Chris said we
looked at when are they when is
criticality reach so these curves is
when criticality is reached
and this is for the manual contact
tracing here is this tracing probability
and here for the manual this is p so we
see that suppose we 50 are diagnosed it
means that P has to be as big as sorry I
forgot what was
Theta
well I think the original or not was
three if I remember correctly so it
means that if 50 percent
or diagnosed we have to find
approximately 80 percent
of the context in order so we are
sub-critical above the curve and create
a supercritical below the curve whereas
for pi we would have to do have a much
higher usage of apps so maybe 90 percent
if we did the same plot but instead of
plotting Pi if we plotted pi squared the
two curves would be closer to each other
but they would not be identical I forgot
to bring that slide but they would come
closer to each other but not identical
uh finally how about the manual and
digital well it's sort of hard what
should we compare with well one thing we
thought of
one would guess that the two effects
would act independently so let's say
that if the manual contact tracing
reduce the reproduction number by
50 percent
of the digital on its own reduced it by
50 one would guess that maybe the
combined model would reduce them by what
is it
it's 75 percent yeah
so we compared the effect
with the CJ with the
naive guests that they would act
independently so that is what we
compared so if they acted independently
if this is the reduction in the
reproduction number one would guess that
the remaining
Port is similar to the remaining part if
they acted independently
on the next slide we have clocked the
critical combinations of p and Pi for
this thing
3 equal 1
and the critical combinations of p and
Pi for this thing to equal one
here are the curves so this is the line
critical line for the the combined model
whereas here is the critical line if
they would have acted independently
so it means that care
if we did not have this model if we did
not analyze the combined model and guess
let's assume that they act independently
we would assume that we are super
critical here whereas in fact we are
sub-critical here so why is that well
the reason is that if
you are manually contact Trace
that will shorten your effective
infectious period
which will also have an effect in the
digital contact tracing
situation that's as much as I can say is
whether if your manually contact Chase
it will shorten your infectious period
that will also help if you were an app
user you would infect you you would then
be diagnosed a bit earlier I don't know
if I'm able to explain that well enough
but they do sort of help each other in
some sense which is Illustrated in this
figure
this is now the end of the talk and what
are the conclusions well we were able to
analyze given these shortcomings in the
model we were able to analyze manual
digital and combine
using different types of branching
process
the reproduction numbers are not for the
original individual so they're harder to
interpret but we in some situation we
could Define an individual reproduction
number
and the combined model has a better
effect than if the two type of contact
tracing acted independently right now we
are focusing on adding a delay between
the diagnosed and successful manual
contact tracing
the problem is that this limiting
branches process will be a continuous
type so you have an infinite number of
types and a continuous type space so
that makes it harder to analyze that's
what we are doing right now
thank you
[Applause]
any questions I know it's break time but
I like interesting
so the results you're seeing about uh
the two sort of being synergistic the
two different types
um or tracing types I mean
um I'm curious
um if just within if you just treat it
as one one type
what I'm wondering is basically you know
should I think about would I be able to
see the same kind of non-independence if
I think about it just as we're doing
contact tracing and then we improve the
quality of our contact Tracing Our
manual contact tracing those I I feel
like those I wouldn't necessarily expect
to be treated as independent events so
I'm maybe not the first year and uh you
just add an extra manual yeah yeah
so that one it doesn't surprise me that
that's no not that that's not
independent so I'm now wondering maybe
sort of the intuition that these two
would be independent if it's kind of the
same reason that that breaks and it's
way outside my intuition at that stage
yeah
okay
so if I have now if we wanted to
actually analyze
to your word we would want to take the
accounts that eventually they're less
susceptible so you could want some type
of
law of large numbers so maybe in this
case it would be functional first
because
I'll focus on the beginning but even
later on in the epidemic work yes
I mean you predict this small outbreak
but maybe you would like to understand
that all but that he needs to
at least increase episode
which would need to control the
religious process
I I don't think you could do a
differential equation because
effectively your blocks will not die of
Financial Times
the more
inclusion thing is have been filled with
mechanism in the beginning so later on
in the epidemic
you would see the name in this contact
tracing procedures
also by people
that you will not protect them by so
maybe I was infected by you
today
and then tomorrow Joe will add an
infectious contact with me which I was
already infected so it had no effect
and then two days later
Joel is diagnosed
so would he name me if the answer is yes
the contact tracing will happen between
contacts that will not result in an
infection
that is sort of not contained in my
yeah so you could be named because
they were testimate I'm infectious and I
would name you
but uh
still I was not infected
but I was not infected by you when I was
infected by you so that it's this naming
thing that becomes more complicated but
maybe it is
perhaps
yeah
or dominating yeah
yes
isolation
sometimes economics I cannot stay in
isolation because
of the new Factory workers
so how was the impact of you know
people choose
suppose we don't have this assumption
that treatment we get the right way to
minimize that
of course I could see those other things
HIV AIDS and the agents and people say
well this is
possible so how what the impact of
behavior
but it's not necessary
humans
yeah so I think
some things can be included with this
module but maybe at the end mentioned
this in the digital contact tracing
uh perhaps these apps don't manage to
catch all the contacts so maybe you can
sort of say include in one parameter
saying that there we miss some of the
true contacts because the apps you know
you even if you're close to each other
and infect each other maybe you were
only close to each other 30 seconds and
that is not recorded but I think that
could be included in in this model
framework but a much more harder thing
to include is if the behavior changes
with time
so maybe I can save myself here that I'm
only focusing on the initial phase but
yeah and then maybe behavior is more or
less the same but of course later on
you can get tired unfortunately so over
time you should probably
make these things refraction obeying the
instructions Decline and stuff like that
and we haven't considered that
it will stop here I brought to a break
but don't need this
[Applause]